you've got a Tesla then there's only one
accessory that you really need let me
show you exactly what it is and exactly
why if you aren't already aware Teslas
have an abundance of storage so
basically inside the main center console
it is extremely deep and you can fit
whatever you need to at the very very
bottom however it is just that little
bit too deep for everyday carry so this
accessory right here which simply slides
in and out and it's a very basic tray is
by far the only accessory you need in a
Tesla it allows you to hold all of your
everyday items like garage clicker your
sunglasses and some keys as well and it
simply hides away when you don't need it